Soho has returned to socially distant
normality a few drinks and a bite to eat
in the summer sunshine but last night on
an evening called Super Saturday
thousands spilled out onto the streets
and it was chaos
the owner of GA why Jeremy Joseph says
despite the best efforts of businesses
in the area the way the restrictions
were lifted was a disaster it was awful
I mean the whole situation was
completely wrong
this is not what venues wanted there are
two pictures of yesterday there's old
Compton Street which was a complete mess
out of control and people forgot there
was a pandemic and then there were
inside venues where I mean you can have
a look what it's like in there at the
moment
you know we've got screens in between
tables where a reduced capacity it's
completely safe
the sheer number of people out and in
close proximity is a worrying sign many
will be wondering how this fits with
keeping the country safe throughout this
pandemic the government has said it is
guided by the science but the truth is
the easing of the lockdown is really a
grand experiment nobody knows what
effect it will have on the infection
rate and it's clear that in some parts
of the country like here for instance
last night alcohol in quantity is a poor
mixer with social distancing the
government's own scientific advisers
have said the reopening is not a
risk-free next step and those
responsible for policing the streets say
the dangers are obvious the alcohol and
social distancing clearly is going to be
a difficulty and the government needs to
accept that they can't just have their
head in the sand and say everything was
fine there were some some difficulties
with trying to manage our social
distancing and when you put alcohol in
the mix that was that was predictable
but in many parts of the country people
did appear to socially distance
responsibly as they enjoyed some of the
old freedoms the health secretary is
warning tougher measures may be
reintroduced if the rules are flout it
we don't shirk from bringing in more
drastic measures if that's what's needed
to control the virus but the overall
plan has always been through this lip
ding of the lockdown to try to lift the
national measures but also be absolutely
crystal clear that will tackle local
flare-ups when we see them this weekend
wasn't just about the hospitality sector
people have also been allowed to gather
in places of worship for the first time
in months the look and I think is about
three months now or they're about that
we've not been here so it was exciting
is to know that the government did when
the pastor said we are going to do this
we have our procedures in place and
we're ready so yeah overall the
government is claiming the biggest
easing of restrictions so far was a
success the reality is though it won't
be for a couple of weeks until we see
the true cost in terms of infections of
returning to a kind of normal Alex Rossi
Sky News central London